existe ahora la duda sobre si Donald
Trump se presentará un no a declarar que
podría pasar si decide no hacerlo
Buenas noches Rodrigo Así es le ha
pedido el congreso que vaya a testificar
sin embargo dada la historia que tiene
Trump de retrasar los procesos políticos
y denegarse a este tipo de peticiones la
verdad yo no creo que sea muy factible
que lo haga podría ir y presentarse y y
declarar el quinto y decir que no no
contestar sin embargo hacer algo muy
difícil para trompa hacer Por lo cual yo
creo que lo va a negar y hay un
presidente negativo de algunos de sus
gente de su gabinete hace que cercana a
él que se negaron a participar a pesar
de haber sido invitados a declarar Así
que no creo que lo haga Pero puede haber
algún tipo de consecuencia judicial
sobre ello o quién tiene que dirimir si
qué es lo que pasa si no decide
participar
exactamente una una invitación del
Congreso desde Es legal tiene mucho peso
debería de hacerse sin embargo ya
algunos de sus la gente que lo ha
aconsejado no se han presentado algunos
de ellos han tenido procesos legales en
teoría podrías en puestos en prisión sin
embargo Trump va a decir que tiene el
privilegio ejecutivo y como presidente
tiene una excusa y una excepción de
divulgar públicamente la deliberaciones
dentro de la casa blanca como parte del
gobierno entonces va a tardar eso va a
tratar de hablar a la Corte Suprema de
Justicia Entonces no sería algo que
pudiera el comité forzarlo hacer en el
tiempo que tienen antes de que empiece
el nuevo el nuevo congreso o que hagan
elecciones intermedias y respecto a los
nuevos vídeos mostrados por el panel que
han supuesto de diferente en el
desarrollo del caso Respecto a los que
ya conocíamos anteriormente
os digo no hay información nueva ya se
sabía por ejemplo que el presidente
Trump cuando era presidente se negaba a
intervenir y a restablecer el orden en
el Capitolio sin embargo el nuevo vídeo
inédito que muestra a Nancy pelosi
el jefe del senado y otros congresistas
es bastante fuerte en Mostrar la
compostura que muchos de ellos siguieron
y su manera metódica de contactar a los
gobernadores de la zona de Virginia
Maryland pidiéndoles que vayaran que
mandaran refuerzos a la a la este jefa
del gobierno de Washington DC entonces
ahí se ve en este vídeo que el poder de
facto del gobierno lo toman los
congresistas demócratas ya que el
presidente de manera intencional decide
no hacer su trabajo de llamar a las
fuerzas públicas a que lo establezcan el
orden Lo cual demuestra que tenía una
intención de que este proceso
democrático de certificada biden fuera
detenido entonces
muchas evidencias y aún nueva evidencia
indicando lo que el comité lleva
mostrando en todas estas audiencias y
este nuevo revés para Donald Trump llega
el mismo día en que el tribunal superior
del país negó la petición del
expresidente para que un perito
independiente revisará los documentos
incautados por el FBI en su residencia
de Florida En qué posición deja todo
esto a Donald Trump y al partido
republicano antes de las elecciones de
medio término
hay muchas evidencias en muchos casos
abiertos que señalan a la culpabilidad
de Trump de romper vallas varas varias
leyes Entonces ahora lo que esto apunta
es que
el el el abogado general del gobierno
tendrá que levantar algunos cargos y
claro Esto es algo Bastante político y
no toda la gente que lo apoya ha
cambiado su opinión al ver estas
evidencias sin embargo estas audiencias
del comité son muy importantes para la
gente que no está informada o la gente
en el centro incluso algunos
republicanos Escuchar sobre todo los
testimonios de muchos republicanos
cercanos al presidente cuando era
presidente Trump y decir todo lo que lo
que lo que pasó y por ejemplo también
declararon hoy que en petit comité en
grupos íntimos Trump aceptaba que la
había perdido la lección Por lo cual
vemos que la que la gran mentira es una
mentira que Trump está
propagando de manera con una mala con
una mala intención de que quería
afianzarse al poder